maybe coming oh yeah say hi say hi yeah
stop man by using my face hey hey man
hey what's going on you too you know
people call me nowadays people call me
the rant asaurus rex that's what I used
to do makes me feel good
bit too PC lately I wanna be PC if you
have a check the last love you know what
was very interesting there's a phrase
that I used to hear a lot growing up
that you can't say nowadays and this
phrase has three words in it get over it
now why is it that we can't say get over
it nowadays for those people who get
offended by this phrase I want to go
ahead and break it down to you what we
mean when we tell you to [ __ ] get
over it get over entails that the
problem that you are telling us about
right now is in significant meaning that
you are very short-sighted in your
vision because if you say get over to
somebody guess what they come back with
you don't unders on me my problems are
real yes certain problems are real but
the one that you are telling us right
now is not which is why we are telling
you who get over at the other the type
of person that we tell to get over is
somebody that always tells us problems
that are never problems my buckle
ditches then [ __ ] scratch it why must
you always make a big deal over
everything you useless [ __ ] let me even
break it down even further what we are
also telling you is that you spending
your amount of energy and time on this
small problem is a waste for you in
order to benefit you you should stop
complaining and thinking about it or
maybe you should solve it but people
fail to realize today is that a lot of
the problem that you whine about you
already know the solutions to you just
refuse to do it
my mother chase that maybe you should
wipe it after you [ __ ] why do people not
wipe the butt after this [ __ ] I don't
understand sometimes when you take off
your under you see that brown streak
it's like goddamn it I knew I [ __ ] up
today we call those snicker tire marks
and sometimes it just looks like your
girl's hand when she'd be testing her
eyeliner
but color - [ __ ] Dookie get over it
learn to move on with your life I don't
understand how you can be fixated on
something so small and have it affect
the rest of your [ __ ] day the rest of
your week when you could just get over
it
do you know what happens when you let
these kind of go over your head that
aren't really important you tend to be a
lot happier me I just vent all my [ __ ]
out and then I don't do it again I got a
lot of things to complain about I am
overworked and I see stupidity every
[ __ ] day and I say things that y'all
are afraid to say so that's why I'm here
[ __ ] how can your life be so stressful
it just doesn't make sense if you don't
live in a third world country you have a
roof over your head food in your stomach
and enough money to cop you some Jay's
damn dog your life really ain't that bad
talking about you upset because you
can't sell a mixtape
well maybe you [ __ ] suck every time a
[ __ ] rival comes up to me above the
age of it you trying to sell me the
mixtape don't you think there's a reason
why you didn't make it having trouble
[ __ ] ridin with the word toast and
[ __ ] what the hell I'm a rope tonight
toast [ __ ] because sometimes you
make I'm in the home and anybody ever
try to rap out there and I know what's
around the next you just kind of mumble
[ __ ] you it's insignificant imma come
on me thinking with I'm gonna bring a
mini-me by the way some of you guys have
been tweeting me that I should [ __ ]
rap battle dumbfounded let me tell you
something about that sucker he would
roast my ass so fast if I have a [ __ ]
battle right dumb you best believe I cry
on the spot listen David you affect
[ __ ] with small eyes a small
dick your enemy
Oh